this is eight news now live at four live
local now a hotel that will allow
patrons to smoke marijuana in some rooms
opens on Friday we thank you for staying
with us here at 4 30. I'm Denise Valdez
I'm Kirsten Joyce this despite questions
if it's actually legal to smoke on the
property 8 news now reporter Joshua
peguero got a first look at the hotel
near Sahara on the I-15 he also asked
the owner if he's concerned about
possible legal issues
the company behind the Lexi Hotel first
started in Phoenix when they opened the
original concept they hope to make the
Las Vegas one it's Flagship and they say
their cannabis inclusive not just
focused we do not intend to sell
cannabis at our hotels
we intend to permit the use of cannabis
wherever uh the local and jurisdiction
allows us to do under state law you can
only consume marijuana in a private
place unless you have a consumption
Lounge license which still likes he
doesn't have and wouldn't even be able
to get since it's within 1500 feet of a
casino during a tour we saw some of the
Lexi's air filtration system that
eliminates the marijuana smell we have a
cannabis hotel in Phoenix and we use
this and it just makes the rooms crisp
and smell really fresh the Lexi is
allowing those who stay on the fourth
floor to smoke inside their rooms but an
attorney I spoke to last week says
they're operating in a gray area I think
most people would argue that hotel rooms
are public places they're open for
business for public to rent those rooms
the CEO of elevation hotels and resorts
Alexander risk says he hopes current
marijuana laws change we just don't want
to see it change we would love to
participate in those talks and we are
the Lexi hotel is
all 21 and over and the company is also
looking to open up more property in
California including in Palm Springs
reporting near Sahara and the 15 Joshua
peguero eight news now
although the Lexi does open on Friday
work on the renovations we're told
should continue for another two or three
months